Today we're testing to see
what's the difference between a
40, 125 and a $500 racket?
We've got five challenges
Let's see which paddle wins
and if you watch until the end
you'll find out exactly
what is the most suitable racket
for you!
Miikka choose your racket first
The five hundo!
Ah, the Smash racket!
That leaves the Sensei
with the Sensei racket!
now we'll see which racket
will complete
The nightmare trickshot
Emil you’re supposed to serve!
I think so too
You have to be like
really quick with the serve!
So close!
This one’s mine!
This challenge I’m gonna get!
The Smash racket!
Takes the win!
Well, I don't think racket was too much
of a difference in this trick, but it
In this trick but
Smash racket took the win still
So next up
we have Lassi
returning a serve with
each racket
You better work racket!
No success yet
Pongfinity Sensei
You touched it!
Slightly closer
He got it!
One out of one!
So the last serve
They’re slower
they have less spin
Which means it’s easier
to return fast and spinny shots
Next challenge
3 games to 3 points
Each set with a different racket
So we have Samuli
who will be the opponent of the day
Otto’s rackets change
Samuli plays with his own racket
But, will the racket make a difference
Heavy underspin serve with the Smash
That’s a good example of how much spin
you can put with the Smash racket
What a rally!
And he takes it!
With the Smash racket!
Even better than with my own racket!
Not bad!
Let’s see how far
we can get the ball so that it
still comes back to my feet
First one will be the Smash racket!
Yeah that’s coming back!
That’s surprisingly good score
The Sensei racket
Is it gonna come back?
Easily!
Emil prove them why they call you
the boomerang!
That is it, that’s over ten!
Is it gonna come back?
It is coming back!
Now I’m warm
What a drop shot!
Snake!
Very sneaky!
You can clearly see the difference
in the quality of the shots
Set point
Samuli takes the game
against the Sensei racket!
So guess which racket
is this by the scent?
Okay is it under my nose?
Yes
Sensei racket!
Smells like Sensei’s armpits!
Emil!
Which racket is this?
This is pretty difficult I have to say
I’ll say the $500 racket
Otto which racket?
Otto and Miikka
got points!
I was thinking that the smell
is so good that it can’t be
the $50 racket
This is the deciding set!
That’s exactly what I thought!
2 meters over
That’s the difference in
how fast the shots go
Nice shot
Okay now let’s see
if it can deal with
the delicate deciding point
It ca...
Samuli takes it!
The only racket that won was the
Smash racket
that it’s a bit rigged
But it’s not rigged!
Next challenge
Making a heavy spin shot!
One shot with each racket
Let’s see how Lassi returns them
It’s... going nowhere
Let’s try with the Sensei next
Still quite a lot of spin!
Got it on!
With the Sensei it’s
returnable
So that’s the thing
You can’t generate
as heavy spins
With the lower quality rackets
So from these three rackets
which one is the perfect for you?
Let's start with a Smash racket
If you like to play for fun
and maybe get into the sport more seriously
without spending too much money
The Smash racket is a great choice!
As you can see
The spins and shots you can do with it
are easily enough
to reach a solid level in table tennis
and it provides great control
for learning all the basic strokes
Next up, the Sensei Racket
It's also a great choice
for a first racket
and it not only suit beginners
but also intermediates
The slightly thicker surface rubber
and the larger sweetspot on the blade
allows you
to step up your game
and play harder and spinnier shots
with more quality
It's more expensive
but if you are thinking of
seriously leveling up in table tennis
the Sensei racket is for you!
and lastly, the $500 racket
As you saw
the blade and rubbers came separately
and all professional players
use a customized set up for playing
But not all customizable
rackets are this fast
and expensive
If you have reached a level in your game
where you know what characteristics
suit your style
and what speed and hardness
you are looking for
a professional setup
can be good to look into
But if you are not a pro yet
the safer option is to go with a
ready made racket
That you can find from
pongfinity.store